So you can probably guess what this question would be. You
are going to find a persona created by one of your classmates
in use case. And you are going to create a feature
list and a flow for them. And once you've done that,
you are going to respond to their post in the forum,
and hopefully engage in the discussion. You can maximize your chances
of engaging in a discussion if you choose a student who
has posted recently. If you choose someone who posted six months ago,
it might be hard. And hopefully the feature list info that you create for
this student persona in use case will be really perfect for them. But it might
not be. This stuff is not super trivial. And if it's not, that's good. Use
this as an opportunity to see where you went wrong and how you can improve.